رجل كريم
افتقر نتيجه الكرمي ترك قبيلته
ونصب خيمته في مكان نائم
لديه زوجه كبيره في السن عجوز لديه ثلاثه
ابناء
بقي لثلاثه ليالي لم ياكل شيئا ثم فجاه
شاهد خيال من البعيد توقع ان نضيفه اهتم
يعني اصبح مهموما كيف سيستقبل هذا الضيف
كيف سيكرمه ليس لديه شيئا ابنه يعرف طبيعه
ابيه فاقترح اعلاميه يعني يذبحه
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح كل مره اسمع الحياه الفطريه مجد
بالي اي شيء ممتع او يثير اهتمامي لكن هذه
الحلقه بتغير نظراتك للموضوع زي ما غيرت
نظرتي علاقه الانسان بالحيوان علاقه
العربي الحيوان تخيل ان نتكلم عن كيف كان
يتعاطى العربي مع الحيوانات حوله ونفصل
فيها يا الله من كميه المعلومات والشعر
والتصوير السينمائي للمشاهد اللي صورها
الشعراء انذاك كيف تحولت الابل من كائنات
وحشيه الى مستانسه في الجزيره العربيه
والحصان
والصقر وغيرها
هذه مرحله
تمر السنين وينقرب الاسد العرب وينقرب
المها العرب وينقرض الحمار العربي وتاتي
حيوانات غير اصيله وغازيه الى الجزيره
العربيه ويختفي معظم الغطاء النباتي وتكثر
حيوانات مثل القرود في جنوب غرب الجزيره
العربيه هل هذا طبيعي قطعا لا هل نقدر نحل
المشكله هل نقدر نعيد حيوانات انقرضت ليه
اصلا نهتم لاعاده حيوانات لا نتقاطع معها
في حياتنا اشي يهمني ان يكون هناك نمر او
فهد او غزال اذا انا ما بعتله
ضيفي في هذه الحلقه احمد البوق مستشار
الرئيس التنفيذي للمركز الوطني لتنميه
الحياه الفطريه في السعوديه يجيب عن كل
هذه الاسئله ويقدم معلومات بديعه رائعه
ممتعه مهمه يقول ان اعاده توطين الحيوان
واعاده الغطاء النباتي ليس رفاهيه هو
ضروره بل
ضروره ملحه
قبل ان نبدا اقترحوا ضيوفا او مواضيع
للحديث عنها في فنجان على بريد البرنامج
فنجان ثمانيه
اما الان
لنبدا يا اهلا وسهلا الله يعافيك الله
يعطيك العافيه كيف الامور الامور قلت ان
الغرفه بارده تقول لي ايمن
[ضحك]
تدخل هذا الجو جو الحيوان وانك تدرس حتى
حتى لما اقول انك تدرسة
الجامعه اللي تدرس ايش الكليه كليه
كليه علوم قسم احياء وفي علم حيوان وعلم
نبات
ومايكروبيولوجيا يعني بالعاده يعني درستها
في انا في جامعه الملك عبد العزيز
قسم علم الحيوان في كليه العلوم قسم
الاحياء
والماجستير والدكتوراه قطعت فيها الشوط
طويل ما بين اليابان والمملكه وبعدين
تدبست في اداره المركز الامير سعود الفيصل
بالطائف فتوقفت في المرحله الاخيره وبعدين
ما عادت اصبحت شيء ذا اهميه كبرى لانه
اصبح العمل والمنجز والابحاث والدراسه
اللي خلاك تدخل
لعلم الحيوان تحديدا يعني ما كانوا
معارضين اهل الكوكتها
الوظيفه المتوقعه من دخول والله انا يعني
ازعم انه الوالد الله يرحمه كان ديمقراطي
جدا يعني
لدرجه مفاجئه يعني انه وين ما تبي يروح
يعني عنده مبدا يعني اذا كبروا ولدك خوي
روح اختار مكان تجد نفسك فيه وانا اعتقد
انه هذا الصحيح يعني بالرغم انه تعليم
وبسيط جدا الولد لانه
متشرب بحكمه الحياه وبعدها
ومفاهيمها
الاساسيه والحيوان انا اعتقد انه
يصح التعبير نقدر نسميه هو معلم البشريه
من قصه الغراب في القران الكريم وكيف يعلم
ان يدفن
الى اليوم يعني كثير من
المخترعات
والمنجزات البشريه
للامانه مدينه
اللي اللي عالم الحيوان
التامل في هذا العالم بشكل دقيق
وطويل ايضا
يمكن ان يفضي الى كثير جدا من الافكار
وحتى يمكن كثير من المخترعات اللي احنا
اليوم يعني
يمكن تعتبر من البديهيات في حياتنا
اليوميه طائره على سبيل المثال هي يعني
حاله تامل طويل في الطيور كيفيه طيرانها
شكل الجناح شكل الطيران اسلوب الطيران
استخدام الريح في الطيران او الرفرفه في
الطيران
تركيبها
التركيبها الجسماني او الفسيولوجي حتى خفت
العظام القوه مع الخفه كل هذه التفاصيل
البسيطه نعتقد اوحت
للبشريه بشكل عام صح التعبير بكثير من
الافكار ومن الاختراعات ومن المنجزات
ولذلك الحيوان دائما محل دهشه عند الانسان
من الطفل الى الشيخ الكبير وهل هي تساوي
ما بين العربي وغير العربي يعني كل
البشريه علاقتها بالحيوان وحده اعتقد انه
لدى البشريه بشكل عام العلاقه تكون يعني
متفاوته ولكنها واحده يعني
بمعنى انه التاثير موجود عند كل الثقافات
ومنعكس في كل الثقافات ولكن محتمل لانه
الثقافه العربيه
اللغه
متجذره في الثقافه العربيه بشكل عميق
وايضا اللغه العربيه اللغه عبقريه لغه
تتحمل كثير من
الدلالات والالفاظ وبالتالي
استطاعت ان تتعامل مع الحيوان بحساسيه
ازعم انها اعلى من اللغات الاخرى وبالذات
في الشعر على سبيل المثال
وكف يعني ليش فيه حيوانات كثيره كانت
موجوده في الشعر العربي وش علاقتها دائما
بالانسان العربي تلقاه مثلا الاسد الخيل
الصحيح
الحيوان في الشعر له ابعاد مختلفه للامانه
فالشعب العربي
وله مستويات ايضا
مختلفه انعكاسه في الشعر ولكن الشعر
الجاهلي على السبيل المثال قبل الاسلام
كان الشعراء
واقعيين اكثر
في نقل الواقع
يمكن من المدهش انه ان هذا الواقع في بعض
مشاهدوا كان يصل حد الدهشه او يصل حد
الخيال ولكن انعكاسه في الشعر كان يبدو
عند بعض المفسرين للشعر او المترجمين
للشعر
او الشارحين للقصائد الجاهليه ان ربما
الشاعر اخطا في هذا
التوصيف او
يكون لديهم بعض الاستنتاجات الغير صحيحه
واقع الحال انه لا انه
الشعراء كانوا
يتاملون الواقع وجزء من هذا الواقع كان
الحيوان والنبات ايضا
وكانوا يصفونه يعني وصف مظهري ووصف سلوكي
والدارس للعلم
مثلي وعنده هوايه الشعر يدرك لاحقا انه
هذا التوصيف كان دقيق جدا سواء كان على
المستوى
المظهري او على المستوى السلوكي اعطني
مثال
يعني مثلا من الامثله
المدهشه في الشعر انا اعتقد انه بعض
المقاطع الشعريه اشبه
للمشاهد السينمائيه
يعني مثلا في مقطع
للراعي النميري وهو شاعر من القرن الاول
الهجري من العصر الاموي الراء انه ما يريد
في قصيده يصرف ذكر النعام
في البريه وهو يحضن البيض
وهذا الذكر الذي يحضن البيض يحضن البيض
على
وعشاء بمعنى رمل متلبت من الرطوبه
حضن للبيض كان في المساء هو طبعا كان
يراقب في الفجر ولما علت الشمس
وبدا التغريد
المكاء احد انواع الطيور البريه بدا هذا
الذكر يتحرك يقوم من على من على العش اللي
هو اسمه في اللغه الاضحي لانه يدحوه
برجليه يسويه وبعدين يستخدم لوضع البيض
ثم
يصف طريقه نهوض من على العش وكيف العفاء
والريش ينتفش وكيف ينفض
الندى حبيبات الندى التي تكونت على جسمه
في الفجر
ومن ثم
عندما يقف يصف البيض ويشبه
بحبيبته في شكله في ملبسه كيف انعكاس
الشمس
على هذا البيض الذي يسمى الترائك من من
قيمته
وايضا لانه يترك في البريه في بعض الاحيان
في بعض الاعشاش ويسمى الهجان الاصيل
فهذا التوصيف مثلا
يقول فيه وما بيضه
بات الظليم يحفها الظلين طبعا اسم خاص
بذكر نعم
وما بيضه بات الظليم يحفها
بوعسى
اعلى تربها قد تلبد
فلما علته الشمس في يوم طلقه
واشرف مكاء الضحى فتغرد
اراد القيامه
فاسبا الرعيفائه وحرك اعلى جيده فتاود
وهز جناحيه
فساقط نفضه فراشا ندى عن متنه فتبدد
وغادر في الاضحيه
صفراء تركه
هجانا اذا مش الشرق فيها توقدا
باحسن
بالين مسا من سعاد للامس واحسن منها حين
تبدو مجردا
المفسرين لهذا المقطع من الشعر وكثر لاحقا
قالوا ان الشاعر اخطا لانه كيف يحضن ذكر
النعام البيض من البديهي ان تحضر الانثى
وليس الذكر واقع الحال الواقع العلمي
المشاهدات
السلوكيه للنعام في بيئه الطبيعيه ان
الذكر يتناوب مع الانثى في حوض البيض
والمدهش اكثر انه
ذكر النعام ريشه لون الريش عنده اسود
واطراف ابيض والانثى لونها رمادي ولذلك
لانه لون ريشه الذكر اسود فهو
يمتص الحراره ولذلك هو يحضن بالليل وفي
الصباح الباكر
بينما الانثى تحضن في الاوقات الاخرى اللي
امتصاص الحراره يكون اقل مما هو عند الذكر
ايضا من اسماء النعام في اللغه العربيه
وانا بالمناسبه كنت اشتغلت على بحث مطول
لم ينشر بعد في الشعر العربي وحصلت اكثر
من 150 اسم للنعم في الشعر العربي من
اسماء الذكر تحديدا الظليم الذي ورد في
هذا المقطع وايضا الخاضب الخاضب يعني وهو
اسم يعني مشتق من الخطاب والحناء اللي هو
لانه الذكر هذا اسم خاص بالذكر وليس
بالانثى لانه الذكر الوحيد الذي في النعام
بخلاف الانثى اللي يكون لون الرقبه
والقوائم احمر
وهذه صفه خلقيه يعني وتغير فسيولوجي يحصل
في موسم التكاثر ولذلك سمي الخاطب وليس
الانثى لها اسماء اخرى
السطعة
والصعل والفي اسماء مشتركه ولكن في اسماء
خاصه بالذكر فهذه الدقه في التوصيف
انا اعتقد انه الحياه الفطريه اغنت
قاموس الشعر العربي من خلال هذا التنوع في
الاسماء والتنوع في الدلالات وفي الصفات
وايضا اغنت المخيله الشعريه
هذا المشهد يبدو بالنسبه لي على الاقل
وربما لكثير من المتلقين اقرب ما يكون الى
مشهد سينمائي يصف هذه هذا المشهد يصف
المشهد هذا لغويا ولذلك انا اعتقد انه نحن
العام هذا اعلى المجلس الوزراء ان عام 20
23 هو
عام الشعر العربي فنعتقد انه من المناسب
ان نبرز هذه
القيم وهذه الكنوز للامانه وايضا دراسه
علم الحيوان بشكل دقيق وتفصيلي وايضا
الشعر المنعكس في
وصف الحيوان
سيغني
ويفسر كثير من المشاهد الموجوده في الشعر
العربي وعلى ذلك قست هناك يعني مستويات
متعدده لهذا الانعكاس من مستوى الاستعاره
والتشبيه الى مستوى
وهذا طبعا شائع جدا في الشعر عيون النساء
بعيون الظبا وعيون المها
والى مستوى التوصيف مثلا وصف المشاهد
الصيد على سبيل المثال الى مستوى الرمز ان
يصبح الحيوان او النبات رمزا في القصيده
الى مستوى الانسنه وهو المستوى الاعلى من
الناحيه الفنيه ان يضفي الشاعر على الكائن
الفطري نبات كان او حيوان الصفات البشريه
مثل
يعني على سبيل المثال في مطلع
العصر الاسلامي كان سيدنا عمر بن الخطاب
رضي الله عنه
حرم على الشعراء
التصريح باسماء النساء في قصائد الغزيريه
بينما كان الوضع في السابق كذلك
والقصيده المشهوره التي القاها كعب بن
زهير امام الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
قصيده البرد الشهيره
بانت سعاد في قلب اليوم متبول متيم اثرها
لم يخدم مكبوله فصرح باسم حبيبته ولم
يحاسبه الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم لانه
جاء ليسلم يعني ليعلن اسلامه والبسه
البرده ولكن
عمر بن الخطاب رضي الله عنه
حضر على الشعراء فالشعراء الايمن يبحث عن
رمز للمراه فوجدوا هذا الرمز في الطبيعه
في احد الاشجار
دائمه الخضره والتي يلجا اليها المسافرون
في الصحراء لظلها ولكثافه خضرتها ولان
جذورها عميقه في باطن الارض تصل الى منابع
الماء فهي اصبحت شجره الشرح في الصحراء
رمز للمراه في الشعر العربي على سبيل
المثال
هناك مقطع لحميد بن ثوره الهلالي
طبعا هو يصف حبيبته ولكن هو يتحدث عن شجره
الصرح في الواقع
يقول فيه
على النبت حتى طال افنانها العلا
وفي الارض اصل ثابت وعروق
فياطيب رياها ويا برد ظلها اذا حان من شمس
النهار وتيقوا وهل انا ان عللت نفسي بصرفه
من الصرف مسدود علي الطريق
حمى ظلها شكس الخليقه خائف عليها غرام
الطائفين شفيقوا فلا الظل منها بالضحى
تستطيع ولا الفيء منها
بالعشي تذوق وما وجدوا مشتاق اصيب فؤاده
اخي شهوات
بالعناق الذي باكثر من وجده على ظل صرحه
من السطح اذ اضحى علي
[موسيقى]
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
فهذا هذا هذا المستوى من الرمزيه هناك
مستوى يعني اكثر تجلي منه ومن الناحيه
الفنيه اعلى وهو مستوى الان سنه ان يضفي
الشاعر على الكائنات الصفات الانسانيه
والبشريه وهذا وهذا نجد كثيرا في الشعر
الشعراء عليك
ابتداء من قبل الاسلام من العصر الجاهلي
وانتهاء الى يعني اوقات متاخره
يعني
ربما الاشهر من الشعراء الصعاليك
الشنفره
شعراء العصر الجاهلي
والشنفره لديه قصيده شهيره جدا قصيده
لميه العرب وبالمناسبه هذه القصيده
متفرده لانه هناك قول ماثور عن عرب الخطاب
رضي الله عنه الخليفه
ان علموا اولادكم لاميه العرب فهي تعلمهم
مكارم الاخلاق تخيل قصيده جاهليه ولكن هذه
القصيده الجاهليه ليس فيها ذكر للخمر ولا
للنساء
ولكن فيها مشاهد للحيوان كثيره جدا وايضا
فيها هذا بعد الان سنه
عند الكائنات طبعا هو يذكر السباع
الذئب
ولديه ابيات كثيره في القصيده حوله وهي
قصيده طويله بالمناسبه ربما يعني لا يسمح
الوقت بذكره ولكن ساذكر بعض المشاهد منها
رغم اني احفظها يعني ولكن سبعين بيت اعتقد
استغرق وقت الحلقه كامل
ولكن هو ايضا عندما يضفي الصفات البشريه
على الكائنات مثل الذئاب والضباع والنمور
وايضا على
غيرها من الكائنات الوعول
يضفيها مسببه
يعني مثلا عندما يقول
الشنفره
يخاطب اهله لانه طردوا من القبائل وعاشوا
في البريه ولذلك اخذوا الوحوش في البريه
وهناك قصص يعني كثيره في التراث العربي
عندما يقول مثلا انه انا استبدلت
الوحوش
باهله
واستبدلتهم لانه
[موسيقى]
لا يخذلوني
اذا ارتكبت جنايه كما يخذلني اهلي
ولا
لا يخذلوني وهم ايضا في ذات الوقت
اشداء مثلي
وايضا لا يفشون سري
كما يفعل الناس
فمثلا الشاهد في هذا في هذا المعنى يقول
ولي دونكم اهلون
ولي دونكم اهلنا سيد عمل لسن
وارقطوا زهلول
وعرفاء شيئا السيده العمل هو الذئب
والارقط الزهلول هو النمر
السريعه
والعرفاء هو الضبع لانه لديه شعر على على
الرقبه اشبه بالعرف
ولي دونكم اهلون سيدنا عمل
وارقطوا زهلول وارفاء
هم الاهل لا مستودع السر ذائع لديهم ولا
الجاني بما جر يخذل وكل ابي باسل غير انني
اذا عرضت اول الطرائد ارسله
وايضا يعني في قيم عاليه جدا في الشعر
العربي وربما في شعر الصعاليك وفي هذه
القصيده على وجه الخصوص مثلا عندما
يقول وان مده الايدي الى الزاد لم اكن
باعجلهم
اذ اشعوا القوم اعجلوا
وماذا الا بسطه عن تفضل عليهم وكان الافضل
المتفضل
او عندما مثلا يقول
لعمرك ما بالارض ضيق على امرئ سرى راغبا
او راهبا وهو يعقل
اديمه مطال الجوع حتى
اميته بالمناسبه هذه حقيقه علميه اذا كان
الانسان جائع وصبر على الجوع
ينكسر الجوع
وديمه مطال الجوع حتى
اميته واضرب عنه الذكر صفحا فاذهل
واستفو ترب الارض
كي لا يرى له علي من الطول امرئ متطول
ولولا اجتناب الذئم لم يلفى مشرب يعاش به
الا لدي وماكل ولكن نفسا مره لا تقيم بي
على الضيم الا ريثما اتحول
وا
يعني حتى في نهايه القصيده
يتحدث عن استئناس الاراوي وهم اناث الاروى
هي انثى الوعل الجبلي
الحساسه جدا
للوجود البشري ولكن من كثر ما الفت
الشنفره اعتادت عليه وكانه ذكر من ذكور
الوعول
فاصبحت تحوم حوله
وحساسيتها مع البشر في العاده البريه
عاليه جدا ما لم يستانس الانسان لكنها في
البريه ستنفر من مسافات بعيده من البشر
مما يدل انه انه اعتادت على الشنفض الى
درجه عاليه
فيصف ذلك
ترود الاراوي الصح محولي
كانها عذارا
عليهن الملاء المذيل
ويركضن بالاصال حولي كانني من العصم ادفى
ينتهى الكيح اعقله طبعا الاصم هو اسم لذكر
لذكور الوعول وايضا للوعول وتسمى العصم
لانه قوائمها فيها اللون الابيض والاسود
وهذا وهذه الصوره
متكرره لاحقا في صدر الاسلام عند عبيد بن
ايوب العنبري في وصفه
الظباء لانه طبعا كصعلوك هارب في البريه
فلما هجت منه الضباء كان يخاطبها انه انا
يعني انسان مسالم وانا ايضا ابن بلده
وبيني وبينكم يكاد يكونون السبا
بالرغم انه حالي من النحاله اكادوا لا
اورى
فمثلا عنده وصف جميل جدا
في هذه الانسنه
حتى انه ياكل نفس اكل
الظباء الشري وهو نبات الحنظل وزهور
الشركه كذلك
عبيد رائع في في شعره وهو من الصعاليك في
صدر الاسلام
يقول في هذه المشهد
اذقني طعم الامني
او سل حقيقه علي
فان قامت
ففصل بنانيه
قطعت فؤادي فاستطير فاصبحت ترامى
كاني
واجال الظباء الاجار القطعان كاني
واجال الظباء بقفره لنا نسب ترعاه اصبح
دانيه راينا ضرير الشخصي يظهر تاره ويخفى
مرارا ناحل الجسم عاريه فاجفلنا نفرا ثم
قلنا ابن بلده قليل الاذى امسى لكنه
مصافيه الا يا ضباء الوحش لا تشمتن بي
واخفينني قد كنت فيكن خافيه اكلت عروق
الشري معكن فلتوى بحلقي نور القفر حتى
ورانيا وقد لقيت مني السباع بليه وقد لاقت
الغيلان مني الدواهيه ومنهن قد لاقيت ذاك
فلم اكن جبانا اذا هول الجبان اعتراني
اذقت المنايا
بعضهن باسهم وقد دد لحمي
وامتشقنا ردائيا فمازلت مذ كنت ابن عشرين
حجه اخي الحرب
مجنيا علي وجانيه يلا
علاقه العربي اصلا مع الحيوان هل كانت
علاقه لانه يبغى يعيش فياكل منها والعلاقه
استئناس بها ولا علاقه الفه والعلاقه حاجه
في التنقل طبيعه حاجه الانسان العربي
للحيوان ففي تقديري انه لولا الحيوان لم
تكن حياه العربيه ممكنه في شبه الجزيره
العربيه
يعني استئناس
الاوائل للجمل
اتاح
لهم
امكانيه العيش عندما تغير المناخ في شبه
الجزيره العربيه من مناخ رطب ومطير الى
مناخ مناخ جاف
وهذا المناخ الجاف
التنقل فيه غير ممكن بالخيول
الجمل
وصفته كسفينه للصحراء يستطيع الصبر عن
الماء
تقريبا الى اسبوعين وبالتالي
يستطيعوا ان يصلوا الى موارد الماء في هذه
الصحراء
فالجمل بالمناسبه كان حيوانا بريا
والنقوش الصخريه
المنتشره في شبه الجزيره العربيه في
المملكه على وجه الخصوص
تثبت ذلك مستقصد بالنهي حيوان بري لم يكن
مستانسا كان بريا وكان وكان الاوائل
يصيدونه مثل ما يصيدون الضبا ثم تم
استئناسه هناك موقع اثري مهم جدا قريب من
سكاكا موقع الجمل مشاهير وهو في مجسمات
منحوته في الصخر بالكامل
للابن وهذه المجسمات الابل وايضا للحمر
الوحشيه الحمار البري وهذه المجسمات
بالحجم الطبيعي
واغلبها يعني محفوظ بشكل جيد من بعض
الكسور وعليها دراسات مهمه من الباحثين
المتخصصين ولكن المدهش ان هذه هذا الموقع
التاريخي يعود يعود بتاريخ الى حوالي
ثمانيه الاف عام قبل استئناس الجمل
قبل ولذلك الجمل كان حيوانا بريا تم
استئناسه فاصبحت عندما تغير المناخ واصبح
مناخا جافا في شبه الجزيره العربيه وهذه
بالمناسبه دوره طبيعيه
اصبح
الجمل الذي استانس هو وسيله العربي في
التنقل وفي التجاره وفي الحياه بشكل عام
وفي نفس الوقت
الكائنات الاخرى التي لم تستانس هي مصدر
للغذاء يعني لم يكن الصيد مثلا قديما هناك
اخلاقيات عند عند العرب في الصيد الصيد هو
لحاجه
يعني يصيد كائنا بريا ليتغذي عليه لانه
محتاج ان يتغذى عليه
وربما هي تكاد تكون اقرب لهبه من السماء
ان يحظى بصيد ثمين وهذا منعكس عند في في
اجمل تجلياته عند الحطيئه وهو شاعر مخضرم
من قبل الاسلام
واسلم ولديه نصا جميلا جدا يصف فيه رجل
كريم
افتقر نتيجه الكرمي
فترك قبيلته
ونصب خيمته في مكان نائم وهذا المكان قريب
من نبع
ولانه كريم لا يحتمل ان يمر به ضيف دون ان
يكرمه ولكن ليس لديه شيء ليكرم الضيوف لو
مر ولذلك ابتعد في مكان نائم في البريه
لديه زوجه كبيره في السن عجوز لديه ثلاثه
ابناء
بقي لثلاثه ليالي لم ياكل شيئا ثم فجاه
شاهد خيال من البعيد توقع ان نضيفه اهتم
يعني اصبح مهموما كيف سيستقبل هذا الضيف
كيف سيكرمه ليس لديه شيئا فدار حوارا
جميلا في النص بينه وبين
ابنه الكبير ابنه يعرف طبيعه ابيه فاقترح
على بيان يذبحه وان يقدمه للضيف
الجميل في المقطع انه بطبيعه الحال هو لم
يذبح ابنه ولكنه هم ان يذبحه
في هذه الاثناء
شاهد قطيعا من الحمر الوحشيه
مقدمه
المسحل وهو ذكر اسمه ذكر الحمر الوحشيه
يسمى المسحن وقطيع الحمر الوحشيه تسمى
العانه
الذكر يتقدم والاناث تنتظم خلفه وهذا
بالمناسبه سلوك طبيعي في البريه بالرغم
انه قرض الان الحمر الوحشيه في شبه
الجزيره العربيه
قادمه الى النبع القريب منه ليشرب طبعا
ليس بعيد كثيرا عنه فنسل من اهله ومعه
الكنانه التي فيها السهام وربط لها حتى
تمكن من احداها فصاده واكرم ضيفه
هذا هذا هذه الممازجه بين حياه البدوي
وهذه الحاجه الماسه يعني مثلا
استحضر النص فقط لتحضر الصوره
نتخيلها لاني انا عندما القي هذه المقاطع
اتخيل لانه مشهد سينمائي يعني يعرض
في هذا المقطع
وطاوي ثلاث
عاصب البطن مرملا
بتيهاء لم يعرف بها
ساكن رسما
اخي جفوه
فيه من الانس وحشه يرى البؤس فيها من
شراسته نعمه وافرد في شعب عجوزا ازاءها
ثلاثه اشباح
تخاله مبهمه حفاه عراه ما اختذوا خبز مله
ولا طعم للبر مذ خلقوا طعمه راى شبحا وسط
الظلام فراعه فلما بدا ضيفا تصور واهتم
فقال ابنه لما راه بحيره ايا ابتذبحني
ويسر له طعمه ولا تعتذر بالعدم على الذي
ترى يظن لنا مالا
فيوسعنا ذمه فروق قليلا ثم احجم برهه وان
هو لم يذبح فتاه فقد هم
وبينهما عنت على البعد عانه قد انتظمت من
خلف مسحلها نظما عطاشا تريد الماء
ظما ان تريد الماء
فانساب نحوها على انه منها على دمها عظمى
فامهلها حتى تروت عطاشها فارسل فيها من
كنانته سهما فخرت نحوص ذات جحش سمينه قد
اكتنزت لحما وقد طبقت شحمه فيا بشره اذ
جرها نحو اهله ويا بشرهم اذ راوا كلمها
يدما
فباتوا كراما قد قضوا حق ضيفهم فلم يغرموا
غرما وقد غنوا غنما وبات ابوهم من بشاشته
ابا لضيفهم والام من بشرها امه يا الله يا
الله
فربما هذا المقطع يشرح هذه العلاقه
الوطيده في سؤالك عودا على بدء بين العرب
وبين الحيوان سواء كان هذا الحيوان استطاع
العربي ان يستانسه مثل الخيل
والابل
او لم يستطع استئناسه وكان مصدرا لغيره
استانس الابل ابن الخيل
ليس لدي اجابه دقيقه حول ذلك ولكن اعتقد
في حدود اطلاعي ربما المتخصصين في هذا
المجال يفتون اكثر ان
اكتشاف
هيئه الاثار والجهات المعنيه بالاثار
والمتخصصين في الاثار في المملكه
لموقع المقر الموجود شرق
مدينه ابها في جبال الثروات وهذا الاكتشاف
كان في فتره
قبل سنوات الملك عبد الله رحمه الله عليه
وهذا الاكتشاف دل على ان
استئناس الخيل
بدا في شبه الجزيره العربيه وليس كما هو
شائعا في الادبيات انه في وسط اسيا لان
هذا الموقع وجدت به مجسمات لرؤوس الخيل
بدون لجم
ومجسمات باللجوم مما يدل اللجام يدل على
الاستئناس وعمرها 9000 عام تقريبا
ولذلك كان الملك عبدالله رحمه الله عليه
طلب من الفريق البحثي ومن المعنيين
والمسؤولين في هذا المجال ان يقيموا متحفا
ويطوف به متاحف العالم ليطلعوا العالم على
الحضارات القديمه التي كانت في شبه
الجزيره العربيه فاعتقد ان استئناس الخيل
واستئناس الابل كانت اولا في شبه الجزيره
العربيه اذا لم يكن هناك دلائل اخرى
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للصقر حتى الصقور بالمناسبه رياضه
السقاره هي رياضه
منتشره في وسط اسيا وممتده في اسيا الى
شبه الجزيره العربيه ولكن لدينا دلائل ان
رياضه الصقاره بالمناسبه في هذا الموقع
الذي ذكرته انفا هناك
ادله على استخدام الصقور في الصيد
وهناك ادله على ان هذه الرياضه ترجع الى
12 الف عام في الشبه الجزيره العربيه مما
يعني ان هذه
ان استخدام الصقور في الصيد او الصقاره هي
حاجه هو رياضه تحولت لاحقا
اصولها عريقه وقديمه في شبه الجزيره
العربيه ومن فضل الله ان
قبل سنوات بسيطه اعلن اسس نادي الصقور
ونادي الابل ايضا ونادي الصقور لديه
نشاطات كثيره مخصصه ومتعلقه بالصقور
والاعتناء بالصقارين وعددهم كبير جدا في
المملكه
وايضا لديهم عنايه خاصه بالصقور وتعاون
كامل بين نادي الصقور وبين المركز الوطني
لتنميه الحياه الفطريه بما في ذلك
المحافظه على
بعض الانواع المهدده بالانقراض وحظر
الانواع المعدده من الاستخدام واغناء
المواكر ولدى نادي الصقور يعني في تجربه
مهمه جدا
برنامج يسمى برنامج هدد هذا البرنامج
تعاونوا فيه مع المركز الوطني لتنميه
الفطريه وكانت فكرته مبنيه على اغناء
المواكر التي
اما انها اصبحت خاليه او اصبح فيها ذكر
فقط بدون الانثى او انثى بدون الذكر فكان
البرنامج هو في اعاده احياء هذه المواقر
واعاده الحيويه لها
[موسيقى]
من ناحيه المبدا كل الكائنات المستانسه
التي تسمى
بمفهوم اليوم كائنات زراعيه هي بالاساس
كانت كائنات بريه
كل النباتات التي يعتمد عليها الانسان في
تغذيته سواء
خضروات او فواكه او حبوب هي بالاساس
كائنات فطريه
تم
استئناسها ان كان حيوانا او تطويرها
وتحويرها ان كانت نباتا
والتركيز في الانتخاب على صفات معينه
يتطلبها او تتطلبها الحاجه البشريه مثلا
ابقار ذات انتاج لانتاج اللحوم ابقار
لانتاج الالبان
وغيرها يعني الحبوب كذلك
يتم تطويرها وطبعا قديما كان التطوير يحدث
بالانتخاب لصفات تظهر او طفرات تظهر بشكل
طبيعي فيتم تكريسها من خلال هذا الانتخاب
تطويره ثم لاحقا اصبحت الهندسه الجينيه
تلعب دورا كبيرا في مساله تطوير
المواد الغذائيه وايضا المنتجات الاخرى
ولذلك الاصول لكل الكائنات التي يعتمد
عليها الانسان في معيشته هي اصول بريه
ولذلك من المهم جدا ان نحافظ على الاصل
البري لان النسخه الاصليه لديها قدرات
وممكنات طبيعيه مكنتها من ان تتجاوز
التغيرات المناخيه على مدى الاف السنين
الى ان وصلت الى يومنا هذا بما في ذلك
الامراض وغيرها ولذلك عندما تحدث مشكله في
القطاع الزراعي يكون في بعض الاحيان
المخرج او الحل هو في الطبيعه هو في
الكائنات الفطريه وفي الاصل او الجذر
البري الذي لم يتغير ولم يتحول ولذلك من
المهم جدا المحافظه على النقاء الوراثي
للانواع الفطريه يعني ليس هناك في المفهوم
الحياه الفطريه يجب ان تحافظ على الانواع
فطريا بمعنى وهذه اللفظه بالمناسبه عودا
على بدء في اللغه العربيه
لفظ عبقريه
بمعنى انه باللغه الانجليزيه
الحياه الفطريه تسمى الوايت لايف ولما
نرغب التعبير عن الحياه البحريه نقول
المارين لايف ولكن في اللغه العربيه نقول
الحياه الفطريه سواء كانت في البر او
البحر او الجو لماذا لان لفظه الفطري تعني
الكائن كما اوجده الله كما خلقه الله على
فطرته على فطرته كل مولود يولد على الفطره
وداني او اسراني او مجلساني في الحديث
النبوي وايضا فتره الله التي فطر الناس
عليها في القران الكريم كل النصوص الشرعيه
سواء في القران الكريم او في السنه
المطهره المشرفه
في شواهد كثيره على معنى الفطره
وهذا معنى مهم جدا وهو الشيء الموجود كما
خلقه الله كما فطره الله
وهذا مهم جدا لانه اي نوع يتم تهجيينه لا
يصلح ان يكون نوعا بريا ولا ينبغي اعاده
توطينه هذا اصبح نوع هجين يمكن ان يصلح
للجانب الزراعي للاستثمار البشري ولكن ليس
للاستعاده في البريه او استعاده النظم
الطبيعيه لحيويتها في فرق بين الحلال
الفطريه والبريه واللي هي
نفسها والحياه الفطريه
لفظه اكثر شموليه بين البر والبحر والجو
وهي لفظه كما قلت عبقريه الفطري تعني ذلك
الحياه البريه
مفهومها يعني في الترجمه يمكن تطبق الحياه
الفطريه
ودي اعرف مثلا البقره
في شكلها البري او الفطري
هي ايضا اقدر اتخيلها الان نعم
كيف اصل الحقيقه كيف الاصل الحقيقي
يمكن ان تشاهدوا في الكائنات الفطريه التي
لم
يطرا عليها اي تغيير بشري او تدخل بشري في
صفاتها على سبيل المثال كلنا نعرف في
افريقيا الجواميس البريه
هذا الجاموس بري ولكن هناك جواميس زراعيه
موجوده في معظم المناطق الزراعينه
والجواميس تحتاج مياه كل هذه الجواميس
التي تستخدم في الزراعه سواء في الحرث او
كمصدر
للالبان او للحوم او غيرها الجلود او
غيرها
مصدرها هو من الجواميس البريه وهذه
الجواميس البريه التي نعرفها في افريقيا
ونشاهدها في الافلام الوثائقيه هذا هو
الاصل البري
نتحدث عن
الحمار المستانس الحمر البريه الوحشيه
طبعا الحمر الوحشيه التي كانت في شمال
الجزيره العربيه ليست الحمار المخطط شيء
مختلف شيء مختلف تماما
ولكن لونها اميل للون الاحمر يعني اللون
البني الفاتحه المحمر مع وجود خط داكن من
الشعر من اعلى الراس وامتدادا لكامل الظهر
الى الذيل هذين هذا انقرض من شبه الجزيره
العربيه ولكن لازال موجود حمر وحشيه طبعا
تحت انواع عديده في الهند على سبيل المثال
وهو الاقرب الذي كان في شبه الجزيره
العربيه وهم من انواع المحتمل استعادتها
لانها لازال هذا الاصل البري موجودا طبعا
في نظام
اعاده التوطين يجب الا تعيد كما اسلف
توطين اي نوع هجين
ولكن اذا النوع انتهى تماما
وساضرب مثالا عليه في المملكه
فاننا
من الممكن ان نستعيد اقرب تحت نوع لتحت
النوع الذي كان موجودا في شمال الجزيره
العربيه وانقرض او نستعيد اقرب نوع للنوع
الذي كان في شبه الجزيره العربيه وانقرض
ولكن يجب ان يكون صافيا من الناحيه البريه
وهنا يكون
التركيز لاستعاده دور هذا النوع في النظام
البيئي وليس المحافظه على النوع على سبيل
المثال
كان يوجد في شبه الجزيره العربيه النعم
وسبقا ذكرنا شواهد في الشعر على النعم
النعم الذي كان موجوده في شبه الجزيره
العربيه هو النعام احمر الرقبه وهو موجود
في شرق افريقيا ولكن تحت النوع الخاص بشبه
الجزيره العربيه الذي انقرضت تقريبا في
الستينيات
حديثا نعم مع الاسف يعني وهناك بعض الصور
حتى له
كان نوعه من النعام تحمل الرقبه ولكن كان
تصنيف العلمي
كاميليوس سيرياكس
نحن عندما فكرنا في استعاده النعام في شبه
الجزيره العربيه واستعاده دور في النظام
البيئي
النسخه الاصل انتهت مع الاسف
فاحضرنا الاقرب لها وهو الموجود في الشرق
افريقيا نعم الرقبه ايضا نفس النوع ولكنه
تحت نوع مختلف تصنيف العربي كان يستبث
الذي احضرناه
وتم اكثاره في مركز الامير سعود الفيصل
وهو احد المراكز التابعه للمركز الوطني
لتنميه الحياه الفطريه وتمت استعادته
واعاده تعطينه في محميه الامام سعود بن
عبد العزيز التي كانت تسمى محاسبه الصيد
سابقا وبالمناسبه هذه من انجح برامج اعاده
التوطين للنعام في المملكه كانت في هذه
المحميه
واستطعنا بفضل الله وبفضل الجهود التي
بذنت من تاسيس مجموعات متكاثره ذاتيا في
البريه وهذا هو الهدف من برامج اعاده
التوطين وكم وصل عددها
وصلت في بعض المراحل الى المئات داخل
المحميه ولكن
مساله العدد ليست جوهريه في برامج اعاده
التوطين والاستعاده
الجوهر هو ان تتكون مجموعات متكاثره ذاتيا
ومستدامه ماذا يعني مستدامه متكاثره ذاتيا
ان تتكاثر بدون تدخل بشري ومستدامه ان
تكون متوازنه مع الكفاءه الرعويه في
المنطقه المطلقه فيها يعني من غير المنطقه
يعني يكون لدي محميه مثلا
مساحتها الف او الفين او خمسه الاف كيلو
متر مربع وكفاءتها الرعويه لا تتسع لاكثر
او لا تحتمل
الكفاءه الرعويه قدره المراه على اعاله
هذه القران لانه من اين سياكل اذا كان
متكاثر ذاتيا معناته بدون تدخل بشري اذا
يجب ان يجد غذائه
واحتياجاته الطبيعيه للحياه وللاستدامه من
البريه
فسيعتمد على النباتات البريه اذا كانت
وفره النباتات في هذه المنطقه المحميه لا
تتسع الا لالف راس
ستصبح مشكله اذا كان لدي 1500 او الفين
راس لانه سيصبح هناك راي جائر مثل الذي
يحصل في الاغنام على سبيل المثال يعني
مشكله الراي الجاري احد المشاكل البيئيه
الاساسيه وهي بسبب كثافه الراي اكثر من
قدره المراه على التجدد الطبيعي وبالتالي
يحصل التصحر وانقراض كثير من انواع
النباتات وهذه الحاله تتكرر حتى لدى
الحيوانات البريه كذلك يجب اذا اعدت
التوطين هدف اعاده التوطين او اي عمليه او
اي برنامج لاعاده التوطين هدفه الاساسي هو
تكوين مجموعات متكاثره ذاتيا من هذا النوع
المستهدف ومستدامه
والاستدامه تعني ان تكون الاعداد متوازنه
مع الكفاءه الرعويه لابد ان تجرى دراسات
للكفاءه الرعويه
للعدد الذي يمكن ان تحتمل هذه المنطقه
بالذات اذا كانت المنطقه مسيجه وبعض
المحميات لدينا وهي قليله والغاء واغلب
المحميات ليست مسيجه والاصح هي ان لا تكون
مسييجه
والحيوانات تنتقل بحريه من مكان الى اخر
على طبيعتها وعلى سجيتها
ومثل هذا النعام ما عاد نقدر يعني لا يصلح
نقول عليه نعم عربي
هو لا يصح ان نقول عليه نعم عربي لاننا
نعم العربي مع الاسف انقرض تماما ولكنه
نفس النوع
التنوع اخر هناك اختلافات بسيطه ولكن
استطيع ان اقول انه النعم العربي كان
قريبا جدا ربما بنسبه 95% او اكثر الى هذا
الذي استعدناه طيب وش فيه من الحيوانات
الثاني اللي انقرضت في الجزيره العربيه او
شبه الجزيره العربيه
عندنا الاسد على سبيل المثال الاسد
انقرض طبعا هل كان الاسد عربيا او كان
الاسد اسيويا الان لما ننظر
لانتشار الاسود في العالم موجوده في
افريقيا الاسود وايضا موجوده في اسيا في
الهند فقط في محميه تسمى بارك في غرب
الهند هي المكان الوحيد الذي لا زالت
الاسود موجوده فيه لو الاسد الاسيوي طبعا
هو اصعب قليله من الاسد الافريقي واللبده
اثار قليلا ويتوقع انه الاسد العربي كان
اما
شبيها بالاسد الاسيوي او قريبا جدا منهم
الفهود ايضا كانت اقرب منها الافريقي اقرب
بنعم من الافريقي اكيد
ايضا الفهود كانت تنتشر في شبه الجزيره
العربيه ويمكن قبل خمسين سنه او اكثر
قليلا مع الاسف يعني
اواخر الفهود تم تسجيلها حتى انها هناك
بعض الصور
لها ونحن نعمل الان على استعادتها
بالمناسبه في المركز الوطني لتنميه الحياه
الفطريه الحمر الوحشيه كانت موجوده
وانقرضت عليك ان تبحث وكنا قد بدانا
برنامجا ولكنه تاثر في مركز الامير سعود
الفيصل ولكن من الممكن
نستعيد هذا النوع مره اخرى من اقرب تحت
نوع له مثل ما حصل في النعام احمل الرقبه
على سبيل المثال
الظبي العفري
مع الاسف انتهى لدينا كان في شبه الجزيره
العربيه ثلاثه انواع من الظباء ظبي الريم
والظبي يفضل مناطق الرمليه والظبي العربيه
والظبي الجبلي في المناطق الجبليه والعفري
في المناطق الحصويه المفتوحه ولكن العفري
مع الاسف انتهى ليس هناك اي افراد صافيه
من الناحيه الوراثيه يمكن ان تكافرها
وتعيد توطينها فنحن الان نكاتر ونعيد
توطين
الصافيين وراثيا الظبي الريم وظبي الادمي
المها العربي المهن العربي قصه نجاح مذهله
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه في هذا في هذا
المجال ايش اللي حصل لانه البهل العربي
كان
طبعا تدهور كان منتشرا في شبه الجزيره
العربيه بشكل واسع تقلص انتشار تدريجيا
نتيجه
لدخول السيارات رباعيه الدفع والاسلحه
الاوتوماتيكيه والاسلحه بشكل عام الناريه
فاصبحت المعادله غير متكافئه بين الصياد
وبين المهر المهر طبعا يفضل البيئات
الصحراويه وانتشاره كان واسعا في الربع
الخالي وايضا في شمال
صحراء النفود وفي صحراء الدهناء كانت
ترتبط المجموعه الجنوبيه بالشماليه من
خلال صحراء الدهنه وايضا في شمال شبه
الجزيره العربيه
العراق وفي سوريا والاردن وجزمه فلسطين
هذه نطاق توزيع الطبيعي ولكن اعداده
تدهورت تدريجيا الى ان وصل الى الانقراض
من البريه تماما فاصبح مسجل كنوع منقرض في
البريه ولكن من حسن الحظ كانت هناك افراد
من المها العربي موجوده في بعض المجموعات
الخاصه
وايضا الاتحاد
الدبليو اف في الصندوق الدولي
للحياه البريه او الحياه الفطريه
قام بعمليه سماها عمليه المها العربي في
الستينيات
وجاء الى شبه الجزيره العربيه واستطاعوا
ان يمسكوا قبل الانقراض التام لانهم
شايفين ورائح الى حافه الانقراض فجمعوا
ثلاثه افراد رؤوس من البريه في المنطقه
بين المملكه واليمن
واهداهم الملك سعود رحمه الله عليه في ذلك
الوقت زوجا من المعهد العربي من المجموعه
الخاصه التي كانت تتوافر لديه وايضا بعض
الشيوخ في الخليج في الكويت وفي قطر عهده
لهذا البرنامج افراد فتكون قطيع من تسعه
افراد تم نقلها الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وتم اخضاعها لبرنامج رعايه
بيطريه
ورقابه كامله واكثار في الاسر بالفعل هذا
حصل في الستينيات في عام 1972 سجل انقراض
المها العربي تماما من شبه الجزيره
العربيه ويعتقد هناك بعض التسجيلات في
بعدها بسنوات بسيطه ربما اربعه وخمس سنوات
في محميه عروق معارض الحاليه هناك بعض
المشاهدات والتسجيلات ولكن عموما في هذه
الفتره كان التسجيل ان المهن العربي اصبح
منقرضا
منقرضا في البريه
بعدها بعشر سنوات من هذا التاريخ استعاده
سلطنه عمان
مجموعه من المجموعه التي تم اكثارها في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في عام 1982
وتم اطلاقها في محميه جده الحراشيس في وسط
عمان
وهذا البرنامج
انطلق في البدايات بشكل جيد ومع الاسف
لاحقا تاثر ولكن نحن بدانا في عام 1986 في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وبدانا بشكل قوي وعلمي ومتماسك واستطعنا
ان نؤسس قطيعا يحتوي على اكثر من 90% من
التنوع الوراثي للمهل العربي في العالم
فاستجلبنا المها من كل مكان استطعنا ان
نستجلبوا من مجموعه خاصه كانت متوافره في
لدى الملك خالد رحمه الله عليه في مزرع
تملي خالد في الثمامه الذي تحولت لاحقا
الى مركز الملك خالد الابحاثريه
وهو يتبع حاليا للمركز الوطني لتنم
الفطريه وايضا من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ومن الاردن ومن مصادر مختلفه
واصبح لدى لدى المركز الوطني الفطريه
قطيعا
منوعا وراثيا وهو الافضل في التنويع
الوراثي على مستوى العالم لانه
يحتوي على اكثر من 90% من تنوع المهام
واعدنا توطينهم في المره الاولى كانت في
محميه محافظه الصيد التي تحولت لاحقا الى
محميه الامام سعود بن عبد العزيز ونجح
الامير سلطان رحمه الله عليه كان عراب هذا
وهو الامير سعود الفيصل رحمه الله عليهم
اجمعين كانوا عرابين هذا البرنامج
المهم جدا
وباحتفال دولي تم اطلاقه في المحازه
ونجح
ونجحت المحازه بشكل مذهل الى درجه ان في
2013 حصرت على جائزه من امانه مجلس
التعاون
كافضل محميه بريه في دول مجلس التعاون
واصبحت بعد تقريبا عشره الى 15 سنه محميه
محص الصيد هي ممونه لبرامج اعاده التوطين
وكان التخطيط شامل واستراتيجي ان نعيد
المها العربي في ثلاثه مجموعات كبرى
لنستعيد حياته الطبيعيه كما كانت في
السابق مجموعه كبرى في وسط شبه الجزيره
العربيه ومجموعه اخرى كبرى في جنوب شبه
الجزيره العربيه ومجموعه الثالثه في شمال
شبه الجزيره العربيه طبعا اتحدث عن
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تمثل ثلثي شبه الجزيره
العربيه وبالتالي
نتحدث عن شبه قاره من فضل الله وبالفعل
نجح اعاده التوطين في وسط المملكه وايضا
اعدنا توطينه في جنوب المملكه في محميه
عروق بني معارض التي سجل فيها كما اسلفت
المشاهدات الاخيره ربما في عام 76
للمحر العربي
ومؤخرا عادنا اطلاقه بالتعاون مع المحميات
المحميات الملك سلمان وايضا مع المحميات
التي تديرها الهيئه الملكيه لمحافظه العلا
وايضا مع محميه الملك عبد العزيز ومع
محميه الامام تركي بن بن عبد الله اعدناه
لشمال المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وربما قراتم في في وسائل التواصل وفي
الاخبار ان اول الولادات فصلت البريه
بعد انقطاع الدام تقريبا 90 عام
في في شمال المملكه فاليوم لدينا ثلاثه
مجموعات للمهل العربي نحن نعمل بشكل
استراتيجي اعاده التوطين لا تعني انك تعيد
هذه الكائنات الى جزر معزوله ولكن لدينا
في الاستراتيجيه التي
عمل عليها المركز الوطني تنتحر الفطريه
المحميات مترابطه مع بعضها يعني هناك شبكه
من المناطق المحميه وهناك ممرات امنه تربط
بين المناطق المحميه لضمان التدفق الجيني
للانواع المعاد التوطينها ولذلك كل
المناطق التي اعيد التوطين فيها سواء في
محميه الملك سلمان في نيوم في
احميات العلا في شرعان في محميه الغراميل
في محميه الامام تركي بن عبد الله في
محميه الملك عبد العزيز في محميه الملك
خالد في الثمامه
قريبا جدا سيكون ان شاء الله في محميه
الامام عبد العزيز بن محمد في الصمام لو
تلاحظ ان هناك استراتيجيه لاعاده التوطين
ولضمان الممرات الامنه للتدفق الجيني
لاستعاده هذا النوع للسياراتيه الاولى
عشان تكون المحميات متصله مع بعض وهذه
تكون امنه في التنقل ما بينها بدون ما حد
بالضبط طبعا المها العربي قصه نجاح لانه
استطعنا بفضل الله مع الشركاء الاخرين في
الاقليم تخفيض مستوى التهدد من منقرض في
البريه الى الى مهدد بالانقراض بشكل حرج
وهو ادنى الى مهدد بالانقراض الى
اللي هو معرض للانقراض تبقى لنا درجه
واحده ونخرج من دائره التهدد تماما
فتخفيض نوع بالمقياس الدولي
منقرض في البريه الى معرض للانقراض اربع
درجات المستوى المقياس الدولي هو انجاز
ليس
وطنيا ولا اقليميا بل هو انجاز دولي الان
يحتفي بها العالم هناك لقاء
سجلت قبل فتره
لصحيفه الاندبندر البريطانيه كان حول هذا
المنجز للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
بالمناسبه بتظافر جهود ليس فقط المركز
الوطني لتنميه الفطريه ولكن كل الشركاء
وحتى الناس لانه مهم جدا تكون هذه العلاقه
يعني منسجمه ووطيده ونحن نعول كثيرا على
وعي الناس وعلى ثقافتها وعلى اهتمامها
وعلى
حمايه هذه الانواع التي تعتبر
مميزه هو من مسماه المها العربي لانه لا
يوجد خارج شبه الجزيره العربيه هو نوع
متوطن في شبه الجزيره العربيه ويختلف على
المهر انواع المهرى الم في القاره
الافريقيه بماذا انا النمر العربي النمر
العربي كذلك النمر العربي قصه نجاح ملهمه
ايضا في المملكه العربيه السعوديه يعني
بداناها في المركز الوطني لتنميه الحياه
الفطريه الان يستكملها او نستكملها مع
الزملاءنا في
الهيئه الملكيه لمحافظه العلى التي انتقل
اليها برنامج
الاكثار في الاسر برنامج المحافظه
الاكثار في الاسر
مصطلح تعني عندما يصل النوع الى درجه
الانقراض في البريه او التهدد بالانقراض
بشكل حرج وهي الحاله التي وصل لها النمر
العربي لا بد من اجراء برنامج
لاكثار هذا النوع في المسيجات
لتعزيز اما تعزيز المجموعات البريه ان كان
هناك مجموعات بريه قليله جدا واعدادها
بسيطه او لاعاده توطين من المناطق التي
انقرض منها
[موسيقى]
اشكرك على هذا السؤال لانه النمر بالضبط
هو ليس
كائنا مستهدفا من اجل اللحم يعني من اجل
الغذاء ولكنه مستهدف لتداخله مع الرعاه
مثل الذئب ومثل الضبع مثل الحيوانات
المفترسه
والنمر عندما ننظر الى الهرم الغذائي
الطبيعي في النظم البيئيه في العالم انا
اتحدث الان عن المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وتحديدا في المناطق جنوب غرب المملكه التي
ينتشر فيها النمر العربي المناطق الطبيعيه
اللي انتشار النمر العربي نجد النمر
العربي على قمه الهرم الغذائي
النمر العربي وجوده هو مؤشر لسلامه النظام
البيئي ككل لماذا
لان النمر العربي
يعتمد على فرائس
هذه الفرائش يتحكم في اعدادها ويتحكم في
انتشارها ما الذي ترتب على انقراض النمر
العربي من معظم مناطق الطبيعيه والان مهدد
بشكل حرج في كل مناطق الطبيعيه بما فيها
المملكه ما الذي ترتب على الانقراض معظم
هذه المناطق وترتب على انقراض الذئب ايضا
وعلى من كثير من هذه المناطق الذي ترتب
مثلا في جنوب غرب المملكه النمو عالي في
مجموعات قرود البابون في جنوب غرب المملكه
تضخمت الاعداد بشكل كبير اصبحت مشكله على
القطاع الزراعي مشكله على المدن مشكله على
الطرق مشكله صحيه يمكن ان تنقل امراض الى
الانسان مشكله حتى على التنوع الاحيائي
لانه هذه الكثافه العدديه كما اسلفنا ان
تكون هناك استدامه هذه غير مستديمه لانها
اعداد ضخمه متضخمه يعني في الوقت الذي
يمكن المجموعات البريه يجب ان لا تتجاوز
بين مثلا التسعين الى المئه والعشرين في
حدها الاقصى للقطيع القطعان المستانسه
وصلت الى اكثر من الف في بعضها وهذا
التضخم جاء بسبب اختفاء الضابط وهو النمر
العربي واختفاء الضوابط الاخرى ولذلك هو
مؤشر على سلامه النظام البيئي هذه المشكله
التي تكلفتها ازعم انها تكلف عشرات
الملايين
وغير المخاطر الاخرى التي تترتب عليها
ونحن بالمناسبه لدينا برنامج في المركز
الوطني لتنميه الحياه الفطريه
لمعالجه ان شاء الله هذه المشكله في
القريب العاجل لانه احنا انتهينا من
تقييمها ومن
وضع خط الاساس ومن معرفه البؤر وحجم البؤر
وطبيعه المشاكل ومن ايضا طبيعه الحلول
وتجريب الحلول في المرحله الاولى انتهت
نحن ان شاء الله في قريبا جدا سنطلق
المرحله التي ستستهدف المعالجه ولكن هذا
يتطلب تعاون كامل من المواطنين ومن
المسؤولين في المناطق لان وجود تضخم هذه
الاعداد بشكل اساسي كما اسلفت لغياب هذا
الضابط اذا لا بد من المحافظه على سلامه
النظام البيئي وايضا من التغذيه الفائضه
التي تقدم بشكل مباشر وبشكل غير مباشر
لهذه الحيوانات التي ادت الى تغير جذري في
السلوك وايضا في الفسيولوجيا في وظيفه
الاعضاء نفسها اصبحت يعني تصل الى سن
البلوغ قبل
الوقت الطبيعي الذي تصله في البريه اصبحت
فتره الحضانه للمواليد اقصر وبالتالي
انعكس هذا الى زياده حجم القطعه اذا لابد
ان نعي انه تقديم الاغذيه ونحن نشرنا اكثر
من 300 عن القرود عن القرود نعم كمشكله
ولكن هذه المشكله يعني نتسلسلنا فيها من
غياب الضابط
الان عندنا في القرود عليه انواع الموجوده
في السعوديه نوع واحد نوع واحد نوع واحد
نعم فالجرود المنتشره في الطائف في ابها
في جنوب غرب السعوديه اليوم تقدر تشوفها
في المدينه صحيح
بسبب المشكله فيها وجودها بهذا الشكل هل
هو غياب مثلا زي الفهد وبعض النمر عفوا
ودي اعرف المشكله اللي قيمتها في المرحله
الاولى ليش وصلنا الى هذا اذا هذا مو
طبيعي
ترى طبعا هو شيء غير طبيعي
الكائن البري خلق ليكون في البريه لا في
المدن لا في الشوارع
لا يمنع انه يتقاطع بعض الاحيان كما يحدث
في اي مكان في العالم يعني تشاهد الدببه
احيانا في بعض المدن في اوروبا وفي كانت
او غيرها تقترب الثعالب ولكن ليس بهذا
الشكل الذي نشاهده في مشاكل القرود في
جنوب غرب المملكه هذا هذه ظاهره غير
طبيعيه وهذه الظاهره لها جمله من الاسباب
ادت لها من الاسباب قتل المفترسات
الطبيعيه وعلى راسها النمر
والنمور والذئاب والضباع والوشق وحتى بعض
انواع النسور التي تعتمد عليها من خلال
التصميم وايضا الاطعام هو السبب الرئيسي
لتضخم الاعداد بهذا اطعام البشر لها اطعام
البشر لها له صيغتين اما بشكل مباشر
للتسليه او بشكل غير مباشر عبر ترك
الاغذيه لها في هذه الاماكن او من خلال
اكرمكم الله حاويات
النفايات المفتوحه المتاحه وفيها الفائض
الغذائي ضخم او عبر مراه من النفايات فهذا
هذه التغذيه غير مباشره ولكن كل هذه
بالاضافه طبعا للتدهور بيئاتها الطبيعيه
فتح الطرق العشوائيه
والافتطاب والراي الجائر كل هذا ادى الى
تدهور البيئات الطبيعيه لها تدهور المئه
الطبيعيه وغياب الضابط الطبيعي لزياده
الاعداد وللتحكم في الانتشار والتغذيه
الفائضه البشريه المباشره وغير مباشره كل
هذه الاسباب ادت الى المشكله اذا ما هو
الحل ليس هناك حلا وحيدا للمشكله طالما ان
هناك جمله من الاسباب ادت الى المشكله
ايضا هناك حزمه من الحلول للمعالجه حزمه
الحلول تاتي من ايقاف اسباب المشكله ايقاف
التغذيه وايقاف مصادر الغذاء البشري
المتاح والضخم الكبير عبر تعديل الحاويات
النفايات معالجه المرامي وغير ذلك وايقاف
التغذيه وايضا من خفض الاعداد والتعقيم
والابعاد
ومعالجه
اعاده استصلاح البيئات المتدهوره نحن في
المعالجه
نستهدف ثلاثه مستويات مستوي يتعلق بالكائن
نفسه
البابون
والقروض التي منها المشاكل ومستوى اخر
يتعلق بالانسان الذي هو مجني عليه وجانيه
في ذات الوقت في التوعيه وفي وضع
التنظيمات
وفي حتى اشياء كثيره ايضا مساهمه والمستوى
الثالث على المستوى البيئي في استصلاح
البيئات الطبيعيه عندما ادفع المجموعه
المتبقيه في المناطق انا اطراف المدن ستجد
ماوى طبيعي وملاذ يمكن ان تعيش منه بشكل
طبيعي في الدكتور عبد المسند كان يقول ان
الحل للتخلص منها هو اننا نركز على الاقل
90% منها وهذا صار يعني ما هو بحل يعني
جديد يعني قبل سنتين او شيء زي كذا قتلت
الجمال الموجوده عندها لانها تسبب مشكله
في طبعا انا اعتقد
كمتخصص القتل ليس حلا
القتل ليس حلا اذا قتلت
خفضت الاعداد ولم تعمل شيئا اخر غير القتل
فستنجذب مجموعات بريه جديده
طالما الاسباب قائمه
اذا القتل
وانا لا اعترض على مساله خفض الاعداد انني
اتحفظ على لفظه القتل لانه يعني نحن في
الحياه الفطريه وظيفتنا هي الحياه هي
استعاده الحياه واستعاده التوازن لنظم
البيئي وليس القتل ولكن خفض الاعداد
خفض الاعداد المدروس والممنهج وليس بالشكل
العشوائي يعني مساله 90% وخمسين بالمئه
وهذه لا ينبغي ان تطلق على عواهنها بهذا
الشكل هناك ظروف خاصه لكل موقع خاص نحن
الان لدينا
بورد لدينا خارطه الكترونيه على الشاشه
موزعه عليها البؤر كل بؤره عندما تضع
عليها المؤشر سيعطيك عدد الافراد الموجوده
فيها سيعطيك طبيعه المشكله سيعطيك المنطقه
السكنيه ام زراعيه ام طرق سيعطيك اذا كان
وضعت فيها لوحات توعويه ولا لا سيعطيك اذا
كان تمت الاستجابه للبلاغات فيها ولا لا
سيعطيك اذا تمت المعالجات ولا لا
وهلم جره هذه هي الطريقه العلميه لمعالجه
المشكله الان المقاطنه مع استراليا على
سبيل المثال
لطرحتها ليست مقارنه سليمه لانه الجمل في
استراليا هو نوع غير اصيل غازي
بينما القرود في المملكه هو نوع قصير وان
كان غازيا فاحنا لدينا انواع اصيله
وانواع غير اصيله وتسمى باللغه الانجليزيه
وبالمناسبه المركز عمل على عقد ورشه
بالتعاون المركز الوطني تنميه الغطاء
النباتي للانواع غير الاصيل الغازيه
الحيوانيه والنباتيه
وهناك قائمه وطنيه الان وضعت على منصه
المركزين لمده اكثر من شهر لاستجلاب مزيد
من الاراء بالرغم اننا يعني استقطبنا عدد
كبير من الخبراء واجرينا مقارنات دوليه
فلدينا الان تقريبا 205 نوع من الحيوانات
والنباتات غير الاصيله الغازيه في المملكه
مش المشكله في وجودها المشكله في وجودها
طبعا نوع غير اصيل وغير غازي ليس مشكله
ولكن النوع الاصيل الغير اصيل الغازي هو
مثلا
الطيور المهنه الهنديه هذه الموجوده في
الشوارع الطائره لونه بني ومنقاره اصفر
وارجل وصفراء هذا طائر الماينا طائر هندي
اصلا طائر زينه استجلب كطائر زينه ثم تم
تسربه من
الاقفاص
الزينه او ربما البعض يعني يستحرم بعد ان
ينتهي حاجته في الطائر ان يتخلص منه فيتم
اطلاقه
تاقلم على البيئه وكون مجموعات وانتشر على
حساب المجموعات المحليه لانه نوع يتغذى
على بعض الانواع المحليه فادى الى
انقراضها او تدهور اعدادها او
التاثير الكبير الغراب الهندي على سبيل
المثال في المناطق الساحليه مشكله مشكله
كبرى في نقل الامراض
في الازعاج في التلويث في
قطع الاسلاك التوصيلات
للكبلات
للكهرباء والتلفزيون او غيرها في اشياء
كثيره وهو بالمحصله ليس نوعا محليا هو نوع
غير اصيل وغازي فوق ذلك غازي يعني هو
ينتشر بسرعه هذه صفه النوع الغازي نوع
ينتشر بشكل سريع على حساب الانواع المحليه
هذه هي ويجب مكافحه هذه الانواع الغازيه
ويجب ايضا حظر الاتجار فيها ويجب ايضا ضبط
منظومه العمل فيها ونحن سائرون في هذا
الطريق لدينا الان خطه وطنيه سيتم
الانتهاء منها وطباعتها ان شاء الله مع
التعاون مع عديد من الجهات
لتطبيقها في كل المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وهناك ايضا تقييم لدرجه خطوره النوع غير
الاصيل الغازي هناك تقييم خطورته على
البيئه خطورته على الصحه خطورته على
الاقتصاد خطورته على
على الحياه الفطريه وعلى غيرها من
بالنسبه للحيوانات
والغراب الهندي وبالنسبه للنباتات نبات
المسكيت او البروس
هذا من اخطر النباتات وهو ينتشر الان بشكل
كبير جدا في المناطق الحاره والرطبه
بالذات المناطق الساحليه بشكل كبير الى
درجه يعني مؤذيه وهو نوع ايضا يمنع نمو
النباتات الاخرى المحليه لانه يفرز ماده
راتنجيه تمنع نمو النباتات الاخرى المحليه
وهو نوع غير رعوي ولا يمكن تجريسه من
النحل يعني لا الاستفاده من ازهاري نبات
غير مستسار
اذا يعني مشكله فلا بد من معالجه هذه
المشكله واعتقد زملائنا في مركز الغطاء
النباتي
المركز الوطني عند قطاع النباتي يعملون
على ذلك فيما يخص هذا النبات ونحن نعمل
كذلك فيما يخص
الحيوانات والحيوانات ولدينا برنامج ان
شاء الله سينطلق في 12 من الشهر القادم في
محميه جزر فرسان لانه بادئه فيها مشكله
الغراب الهندي والماينا فان شاء الله
سيكون هناك مشكله
خطه لمعالجتها من في البدايات عساكم
بالنسبه للجروب يعني
يعني
ليش نبغى نتخلص منها يعني ما يعني اثرهم
مجرد انزعاج بشري من حيوانات موجود انت
مقيم في ابها ولا مقيم في الرياض
يمكن عشان كذا البنات هذه الفكره انك الان
يعني انا اعتقد انه التوصيف الصحيح لك في
زيارتك لموطنك الاصل لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
لا
التوصيف الصحيح انك سائح
لانك تزور ابها او عسير
وهي
يعني مكان رحب جدا
واعشقه قريبا كنت فيه قبل يومين يعني
السائح ياتي لايام ايا يكون سواء كان من
سكان المنطقه الاساسيه وانتقل للعمل في اي
مدينه اخرى لا تتواجد فيها هذه المجموعات
بشكل طبيعي
عندما يعود الى هذه المنطقه يعود لايام او
اسبوع او اسابيع مره اخرى الى عمله وهذا
شيء طبيعي وايضا يحصل معي انا في المدينه
المنوره على سبيل المثال ولكن المقيم في
نفس المنطقه
اذا كان مزارعا
هناك هجمات على المزارع صحيح وبالتالي
يخسر محصوله الزراعي الذي تعب عليه طول
الموسم اذا كان ساكنا ترددها على داخل
البيوت يشكل مشكله كبيره وازعاج كبير اذا
كان طالبا في اي مستوى التعليم حتى
الجامعي وجودها داخل المؤسسات التعليميه
لانها تدخل الى الساحات المدارس الى لان
غير محميه
وايضا لانه لم يفهم طبيعه المشكله انه
وجود البواقي الغذائيه في ساحه المدرسه
سبب لجذبها لهذه الموقع طبعا لن يخرج
الطلاب الى الساحه والطالبات بعض الاحيان
وان كانت نادره حوادث العرض او الاعتداء
احتماليه نقل الامراض لانها اصبحت تستخدم
نفس الاماكن التي يستخدمها الناس
المتنزهات حتى
الالعاب الاطفال في المتنزهات التي
يستخدمها الاطفال طبعا بعد العصر وفي
المساء يستخدمها البابونج في الصباح وهناك
لقطات يعني منتشره بشكل كبير جدا فهذا
يجعل هناك يعني مشكله
الامراض المشتركه لزنت وهي امراض للامانه
يعني ممكن ان تكون امراض خطيره
الحيوانات بشكل عام يمكن ان تنقل امراض
مشتركه الى الانسان ولذلك التعامل الانسان
مع الكائنات المستانسه تعامل منضبط هذه
الكائنات مفحوصه مرضيا لديها تطعيمات
لديها على سبيل المثال القطط مثلا في
البيوت لديها التطعيمات مفحوصه بيطريا لكن
تخيل القرد يعني جاي من البريه لا تعرف
يعني اي امراض يحمل سواء كانت امراض
فيروسيه او امراض
بكتيريه او امراض
فطريه او طفيليات
فطبعا احنا ايضا جزء من المشروع الذي نفذه
المركز الوطني تنتحر الفطريه في المرحله
الاولى كان يستهدف سحب عينات الدم من
السته المناطق المتضرره التي ان تنتشر
فيها البابونج بشكل طبيعي وفحص هذه
العينات للامراض الشائعه المتوقع ان
احتماليه النقل لها وبالتالي نستطيع ان
نفهم
المخاطر التي يمكن الصحيه التي يمكن ان
تترتب على قربه من الناس بهذا الشكل او
ربما تضطر ان تاخذ احتياطات اخرى
لاخراج طبعا اخراجه تماما من المدن هذا هو
الهدف ولكن حتى هذا التماس يجب الا يكون
بهذا الشكل هل وجدتم مشكله في النتائج
اللي طلعت من سحب العينات في
النتائج طبعا صارت دراسه سابقه اوليه وفي
الدراسه السابقه الاوليه كان هناك بعض
الامراض المشتركه موجوده
المضادات معنى هذا انه كان يحمل هذا المرض
وهذه مشكله
ويجب في برنامج الصحه الواحده هو برنامج
بمناسبه دولي وتطبق المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
ينظر الى الصحه كمنظومه متكامله
الامراض في الحيوانات الفطريه والامراض في
الحيوانات المستانسه والامراض في الانسان
واليه انتقاله
هذه وضوح الصوره مهم جدا
ليمكننا التدخل لكسر هذه الدائره اذا لا
قدر الله كان هناك امراض
مشتركه موجوده الفحوصات لم تنتهي بعد تمسح
بالعينات وهي خاضعه للفحوصات وسيتم ان شاء
الله الاعلان عنها طيب بمن قلت انه
الانسان واحد من اهم المشاكل التي سببت
تواجد القرود في المنطقه
ودي اعرف في فتره كورونا كان يعني سنتين
من غياب الانسان في المدينه هل اثر على اي
شيء شفته بالنسبه للقرود واختفاء هذا
العنصر طبعا في فتره الحجر في كورونا
غاب الوجود وجود الانسان المباشر في
والاطعام المباشر ولكن الاطعام الغير
مباشر كان مستمر من خلال اكرمكم الله
حاويات النفايات من خلال بعض الناس في
الوقت المتاح للخروج والتبضع يضع
الاغذيه الفائضه من اجل القروض البعض طبعا
لديه حسن نيه انه هذا يعني يكسب الاجر
وانه هذا يكسب صدقه بالضبط وانه هذه
كائنات ولكنه لو عرف ان ذلك يؤدي الى
مشاكل ناس اخرين حتى للكائن نفسه هذا
الكائن لا ينبغي ان يكون بهذا الشكل انت
قاعد تعطيه اغذيه يعني يعني ليس طبيعيه
نسبه السكريات فيها عاليه نسبه
الكربوهيدرات فيها عاليه طبعا احنا لم
نفحص اذا كان لديها امراض يعني سكر وامراض
ضغط وامراض يعني لسنا بهذه الرفاهيه يعني
نبحث عن الامراض المشتركه مع الانسان ولكن
يعني اتوقع لو ربما بعض الجهات الاكاديميه
والبحثيه اجرت ابحاثها ستجد هناك يعني
تغير هرموني والتغير يعني هو التغير
الهرموني حاصل ولكن اقصد تغير حتى في
الامراض يعني يتشارك مع الانسان بالامراض
لانه الامراض المشتركه لا يعني الانتقالها
من كائن من الحيوان الانسان ولكن يمكن
العكس من الانسان الى الحيوان كما تعرف
مثلا في
كورونا على سبيل المثال
واخذت صدى عالمي كبير جدا نشرت بعض
الابحاث انه هناك انتقال من الانسان
لكوفيد 19 لمرض كورونا
للحيوان بالذات
المعتنين حيوانات في بعض حدائق الحيوان في
بعض
الحدائق في العالم
اثبت نقل المرض من الانسان الى الحيوان
والعكس كذلك صحيح طيب قبل
ما تيجي كنا نتناقش من الاشياء اللي كانت
انه انا
ابدا هي ضروره وضروره ملحه وساشرح لماذا
بشكل مختصر
الانسان هو ابن بيئته كما يقال والانسان
هو جزء من المنظومه البيئيه اليوم هل
يستطيع الانسان
ان يعيش في مدينه
ملوثه
الى درجه تصيبه بالامراض
هل يستطيع الانسان ان يعيش
في بيئه
مضطربه ستصبح حياته صعبه وربما تصل في
مرحله من المراحل الى التعذر ولذلك
المحافظه على
الكائنات الفطريه المختلفه وبالذات
المهدده بالانقراض واستعادتها هو محافظه
على سلامه النظام البيئي الذي الانسان
جزءا منه
فاختلال هذا النظام البيئي سينعكس على
الانسان الذي يعيش في المدينه او الذي
يعيش في القريه سينعكس عليه بشكل مباشر
ساطرح مثال بسيط
نحن اليوم
نسمع كثيرا في الاخبار توجه الدوله حفظ
الله
بمبادرات اصل الرؤيه المملكه احد الركائز
الاساسيه التي اعلنها سمول العهد الله
يحفظه من 2016
هي الركيزه سلامه البيئه
بيئات مزدهره
وحيويه سلامه البيئه هي احد الركائز
الاساسيه لرؤيه المملكه 2030
سلامه البيئه ماذا تعني لانسان المدينه
الذي لا علاقه له
بالمهى
الظباء والنعام ان حياته في هذه المدينه
تكون متوازنه طيب ما الذي يجعل حياه
الانسان في هذه المدينه متوازنه ناخذ
الرياض على سبيل المثال
الذي يجعل حياته متوازنه ان يكون هناك
جوده معيار جوده عالي في الهواء وفي
التربه وفي الماء ما الذي يحقق هذه الجوده
هو سلامه النظام البيئي
يعني سلامه الغطاء النباتي في المناطق
المحيطه بالمدينه
هو الذي يولد نسب عاليه من الاكسجين
ويخزن ويسحب نسب عاليه من ثاني اكسيد
الكربون وبالتالي يجعل الحياه في المدينه
ممكنه هذا الاستزراء والاهتمام الكبير
والتوجه الذي يعلن اعلنه ولي العهد في
مبادره المملكه الخضراء وفي مبادره الشرق
الاوسط الاخضر في مبادره المملكه الخضراء
احد المستهدفات استزراع عشره مليار شجره
او ما يعادل اعاده
تاهيل اربعين مليون هكتار كيف ساستعيد
كيف ساعيد تاهيل الاربعين مليون هكتار دون
ان انشئ مناطقا محميه
احد الادوات
لاعاده التاهيل لهذه الاربعين مليون هكتار
المستهدفه هو انشاء المناطق البحميه
باشكالها المختلفه والمتنزهات الوطنيه
وغيرها ايا تكن الجهه التي تشرف عليها
كماده المحميات عندنا
الان لدينا 38 منطقه محميه المركز الوطني
لتنميه الحياه الفطريه يدير عشره مناطق
محميه في الوقت الحالي ولديه منظومه
مستقبليه راح يعلن عنها ان شاء الله في
المستقبل وهناك سبعه محميات ملكيه وهناك
ايضا خمسه محميات تديرها الهيئه الملكيه
لمحافظه العلا هناك محميات ايضا للقطاع
الخاص بالاضافه للمتنزهات الوطنيه التي
تجاوزت تقريبا 500 متنزه وطني وان كانت
مساحتها صغيره ولكنها مهمه جدا لانها تلعب
دورا مهما في المحافظه على التنوع
الاثنائي وايضا في سيف الممرات الامنه
التي تربط بين المناطق ولذلك هذا المستهدف
الاساسي في رؤيه المملكه لن استطيع ان
احقق بمعزل عن
سلامه البيئه اذا انا في مدينه الرياض
اليوم انا وانت والاخرين نتشارك الحياه في
هذه المدينه
نحتاج ان نزرع وهذا معلن في البرنامج
الرياض الخضراء مبادره الرياضه الخضراء
واستزرع سبعه مليون شجره وكل هذه البرامج
التي نسمع عنها واستهداف الاشجار المحليه
لانها احتياجها المائي اقل واستدامتها
اكبر
وقدرتها على الاستدامه اعلى
وبالتالي كلما استزرعت اشجار اكثر في
المدينه
كلما وسعت رئه المدينه
كلما اصبح الهواء اكثر جوده وحياه الناس
في هذه المدينه اكثر صحه وجوده الحياه
بالمناسبه احد مستهدفات الرؤيه
جوده الحياه جزء من جوده الحياه ان تكون
في بيئه نقيه الهواء فيها نقي التربه فيها
نقيه الماء فيها نقي النظم البيئيه تلعب
دور مهم جدا في تنقيه المياه التي تصل
الينا سواء كانت في البحر او كانت في البر
نحن لسنا بمعزل عن البحر
اعلى نقطه في اعلى جبل في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه مرتبطه باخفض نقطه في اعمق بحر
في البحر الاحمر مرتبطه تماما ببعضها
كسلسله البحر ليست مباشره على اي قوه
تنعكس على الانسان مباشره يعني المركز
الوطني لتنميه الحياه الفطريه معني
بالبيئه البحريه معني بالتنوع الاحياء
الحيواني في البر وفي البحر وبالمناسبه
المركز يعني مؤخرا
المركز تاسس من عشرين واحد وعشرين من
سنتين كمركز وطني وان كان يعني ورث عن
الهيئه السعوديه الفطريه التي تم الغاءها
بعض المنجزات السابقه كمراكز الابحاث
والاكثار تحولت له ولكن كمركز برؤيه جديده
واهداف استراتيجيه جديده بدا في 2021
فكان اساسا ان يكون التركيز ايضا على
البيئه البحريه التي ربما كثير من الناس
لا يتحدث عنها ولذلك حتى اختيار الرئيس
التنفيذي للمركز الوطني تمتحن في طريق
الدكتور محمد قربان وهو اشهر من ان اعرف
به هو من اشهر المتخصصين في البيئات
البحريه وتحديدا في البحر الاحمر والخليج
العربي لانه كان يراس مركز البيئه والبيئه
في جامعه الملك فهد للبترول المعادن ولديه
خبره طويله جدا في هذا المجال وبالفعل
المركز عمل
بشكل مكثف على البيئه البحريه وفي تقرير
المركز للعام الماضي
22 سيكون المنجز الاكبر ليس هو الاكثار
واعاده التوطين الذي يشاهده الناس لا انما
هو الاستكشاف الذي عمله المركز الوطني
لتمت الحرف الفطريه في البحر الاحمر في 20
22 المركز تعاقد مع سفينه ابحاث الدوليه
شهيره جدا
وايضا مع السفينه ابحاث محليه اسمها عزيزي
مع جامعه الملك عبد العزيز ومع جامعه
الملك عبد الله للعلوم والتقنيه واشرك
عديد من الجامعات في رحله استكشافيه
استمرت لاكثر من اربعه اشهر في البحر
الاحمر في المياه الاقليميه السعوديه من
الساحل البحر الى اعمق نقطه الى ثلاثه
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف متر وتم استكشاف هذه
المنطقه وسيعلن المركز خلال عشرين 23 باذن
الله هذا العام نتائج هذه الاستكشافات
التي ستذهل العالم ليس المواطنين في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ولكن
ستكون يعني مدار حديث الاقليم والعالم
لانه البحر الاحمر
مقر لاسرار مهمه جدا البحر الاحمر والخليج
العربي نحن نعلم ان هناك مشاكل عالميه على
سبيل المثال نتيجه للاحترار العالمي
وارتفاع درجات الحراره في العالم ادت الى
ارتفاع بسيط في درجات الحراره في البحار
والمحيطات ونتيجه لهذا الارتفاع ادى الى
ابيضغ الشعب البرجانيه في كثير من المناطق
هذه المشكله العالميه انا اعتقد ان مفتاح
حلها في المملكه العربيه السعوديه لانه
نحن نعيش في منطقه حاره
والمرجان في المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
البحر الاحمر والخليج العربي
لديه مقدره على تحمل درجات الحراره
العاليه ولذلك استطاع البقاء دون ان يحصل
هذا الابغاظ طبعا سبب
كل الناس الذين يعني يعرفون الشعاب
المرجانيه هي جنه من الالوان هي الشعب
المرجانيه طبعا هي كائن حيواني
لا يستطيع ان يعيش بدون نبات ولذلك يتحد
معه نوع من انواع من
الطحالب وهذه الطحالب هي التي تعطي
الالوان الزاهيه للمرجان وهذا الاتحاد
يتطلب درجه حراره معينه عندما ترتفع درجه
الحراره ينفصل تنفصل الشعاب تنفصل
الطحالب عن المرجان فيصبح لونه ابيض بمعنى
يموت
والمرجان مسؤول كبيئه في البحر عن تقريبا
حمايه وتوفير بيئات طبيعيه وتغذيه لاكثر
من 25% من التنوع الاحياء البحري نحن
نعتمد على الاسماك الموجوده في البحار
وهذا جزء من مصدر التغذيه البر مرتبط في
البحر نعم مرتبط هذه السيوله التي
تاتي من اين تاتي السير
اذا نظرنا لخارطه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه البحر الاحمر موجود في الناحيه
الغربيه كل يوم يحصل تبخر
لجزء بسيط من مياه البحر الاحمر نتيجه
لسطوع الشمس وارتفاع درجه الحراره في
المستوى مستوى سطح البحر هذا هذا البخار
الماء
عندما يصعد الى الطبقات الاعلى تقريبا كل
مئه متر تنخفض درجه الحراره درجه مئويه
تدفعه الرياح باتجاه الجبال
فيصل على هيئه ضباب الى ابها والى عسير
والى مرتفعات جبال السنوات يصل على هيئه
الضباب ومطر
هذا الضباب الذي
تاسره الاشجار وجود اشجار العرعر واشارز
العتم الزيتون البري وغيرها هي التي
تستطيع هي مصائد المطر الذي نسميها المطر
الافقي يتحول الى قطرات ويزيد احتواء
الماء في التربه والمطر العمودي المطر
الطبيعي الذي يهطل على جبال الثروات
وبالمناسبه جبال قمم جبال الثروات تعتبر
الخط الفاصل لظل المطر يعني معظم الامطار
تهطل على الجانب الغربي على الواجهه
الغربيه من جمال الثروات ولذلك هي اكثر
اخترارا من الواجهه الشرقيه
لهذا السبب فالامطار التي تهطل وتنتج عنها
السيول وتندفع السيول الى البحر في بعض
المواقع تاخذ معها المغذيات من التربه
وهذه المغذيات هي التي تعيش عليها
اللي هي الهائمات البحريه التي هي مصادر
لغذاء الاسماك والكائنات البحريه الاخرى
طيب بعد احنا بدانا بجانب ثقافي
بدينا انتقلنا الى العلمي او العمل عفوا
بدي ارجع للثقافه شوي فيه
للدكتور سعد الصغير كان يقول
انا الجمل نتشكلت ثقافتنا بناء على هذا
الاكتشاف ثم اكتشفنا النفط
فتشكل الثقافتنا بناء على هذا الاكتشاف هل
اليوم احنا كسعوديه فقدنا علاقتنا
بالحيوان
انا اعتقد من
ما يتوفر لدي من معلومات ومن مشاهدات الى
من اسفار كثيره جدا داخل المملكه وخارجيها
ان
المواطن السعودي
ربما يكون من اكثر الشعوب
الشعب السعودي ربما يكون من اكثر الشعوب
في العالم علاقه بالحيوان
كيف
اولا
في الدين الاسلامي
قبل ان اتي في الدين الاسلامي في التراث
العربي اساسا هناك علاقه
حميمه بين الانسان العربي وبين الحيوان
سواء كان هذا الحيوان خيلا او
ابل او اغناما او كائنات بريه وسبق
استرسلنا في في
هذه العلاقه وهذه العلاقه ليست علاقه
عابره انما علاقه وطيده وعلاقه ليست فقط
حياتيه وترقى الى مستوى الجماليه لانه
انسنت الكائن وتحويله الى الى اظفاء
الصفات البشريه عليه يعني ان العلاقه
تجاوزت النفعيه
علاقه
تجاوزت المفهوم النفعي في في العلاقه مع
الكائن الحي الحصول على اللحم او على
الالبان الحليب او على الجلود لا هناك
علاقه اعلى
يعني علاقه العربي بالخيل على سبيل المثال
علاقه عريقه ومنعكسه ايضا بشكل وطيط في
الشعر لاحقا في
الدين الاسلامي يعني الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم لما بعثته ليتمم مكارم الاخلاق هذه
مكارم الاخلاق التي كانت موجوده عند العرب
في العصر الجاهلي امتدت مكارم الاخلاق هذه
وتم تتميمها كما قال الصادق المصدوق صلى
الله عليه وسلم
تم تتميمها بان الاحسان في الاسلام هو ان
تحسن
للعالمين بمعنى ان تحسن لكل مخلوقات الله
البشر والحيوان والشجر وحتى الحجر
ومبدا لا ضرر ولا ضرار هو من احد المبادئ
الاسلاميه اذا هو امتداد لمكارم الاخلاق
وتتميم بالاسلام لمكارم الاخلاق وهذا
التتميم مستمر لليوم يعني انت تجد اليوم
يعني طريقه التعامل مع الحيوان عند
الانسان العربي المسلم
مختلفه تماما فيها شيء من الرحمه
فيها شيء من من
التواصل الذي يتجاوز النفعيه
تخيل مثلا علاقه بعض
الناس بحيواناتها المستانسه طبعا هذا
موجود ايضا في الغرب بعض الحيوانات على
سبيل المثال وموجود عند شعوب اخرى ولكن
ازعم انه عند
المجتمع السعودي وعلى وجه الخصوص المجتمع
العربي الاسلامي
تجدرت هذه العلاقه القديمه عند العربي
وتتممت
من خلال الاسلام ثم الى العصر الحديث
تشوهات التي نشاهدها بين الحين والاخر في
تعاملات غير انسانيه مع الكائن
الحيواني بالذبح بالقتل بالكذا هي
استثناءات تؤيد القاعده القاعده هي
التعامل الانساني الراقي الذي يصل في بعض
مراحله الى نقطه تتجاوز النفط
الله يعطيكم العافيه الله يكرم جزيلا الله
يعني
هذا الوقت اللي اعطيتني اياه
ويعني هذه الحلقه اشكرك مره اخرى على صبرك
كثيرا ولكن كان كنت مستمتع للامانه في
الحديث الله يعطيك اشكرك واشكر البرنامج
الجميل شكرا لكم شكرا لايمن الحمادي خلف
الاعداد وخلف الكاميرات وهاب موسى وفي
التحرير جميله الاحد وفي التلوين عبد
المجيد العطاس والهندسه الصوتيه ضياء
الدين مدني واداره محتوى التواصل نورا
السبيعي وفي اداره التحرير اسيل بعبد الله
هذا فنجان احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر
والتوزيع وننشر كل الانتاج بحب من مدينه
الرياض
الاسبوع المقبل القاكم
[موسيقى]
الحين انتهت طيب بس ايمن عنده اسئله يعتقد
انها سخيفه واعتقد انها سخيفه فليتفضل
مشكوره
دكتور
[ضحك]
الاسد يقال له ان ملك الغابه
وليش هي سفينه الصحراء ليش مو ملكه
جميل
الصفه
ملك الغابه او سفينه الصحراء
اطلقها الانسان على الكائن الحي
واطلقها نتيجه
لعلاقه او شكل علاقه معينه يعني مثلا اطلق
الانسان على الجمل سفينه الصحراء لانه
هو الوسيله التي ينتقل فيها في بحار
الرمال
يعني تخيل انت بحاره الرمال وكانها امواج
البحر لا يمكن اي كائن ينقل الانسان في
هذه الصحراء طبعا اتكلم على العصور
القديمه الا الجمل ولذلك صار هذا الاسم
المجازي لانه المجاز ترى ابلغ من الحقيقه
صار الاسم المجاز انه هو سفينه الصحراء
لانه يتوافر على صفات مظهريه
وفسيولوجيه مكنته من الصبر على الماء يصل
الى اسبوعين ترى بالمناسبه لو اقارنوا
بالبعض الحيوانات البريه تندهش في احد
المقالات تكتبها لنا نحب انا اكتب
انه الجمل يستطيع ان يصبر على الماء لمده
اسبوعين تقريبا
لمده اسبوعين
تخيل المال العربي كم يصبر على النوم
ممكن يصبر على الماء الى 11 شهر فانا مسمي
الجمل
في صبره على الماء تلميذ في الصف الاول
الابتدائي في جامعه المهد العربي
تمام فاذا هذه الصفه الرمزيه اللي اطلقها
الانسان اطلقها لعلاقته معه الجمل هو
قياسا بالبحر هو السفينه التي تنقل في
بحار الرمال الضخمه التي تحتل مساحات
شاسعه جدا في شبه الجزيره العربيه سواء في
الربع الخالي او الدهنه او النفود
اتفضل اتفضل خلصنا المعذره نطرنا
الاسد سمي ملك الغابه
لانه اكبر مفترس
في الغابه
وبالفعل ما يستطيع ان يواجهوا مفترس اخر
يعني مثلا لو واجه الاسد نمر سيفترس النمر
لو واجه الاسد
فهد سيفترس الفهد وفي لقطات يعني مسجله
فعليا لهذا الافتراس يعني لا يستطيع عندما
يفترس الاسد فريسه لا يستطيع احد ان ينتزع
منه الا قطيع ضباع وهو يكون اسد لوحده بس
لو كان يعني مجموعه من الاسود مستحيل حتى
الزواحف لو مثلا الزواحف موضوع اخر موضوع
اخر لكن الاسد بس بدي اوصل الى اجابه
للتساؤلك انه ملك الغابه لانه فعلا لا
يستطيع ان يتجرا عليه احد طبعا لو كان اسد
وحيد مع مجموعه من النظم اكيد انه القوه
تغلب الشجاعه ولكن يعني مجموعه من الاسود
صعب صعب انه يعني يكسر هذه القوه احد
ولذلك سمي يعني ملك الغابه وسفينه الصحراء
حديث التصميم اعتقد انه اسم قديم يعني
اسم قديم ان لم تخن الذاكره هل كانت العرب
تعرف قديما السفينه اي طبعا طبعا
عند
اذا ما خانتني الذاكره موجوده في المعلقات
[موسيقى]
عشائر من الشرقيه
من شعراء المعلقات اللي هو طرفه طرفه ابن
العبد فما يحضرنا الابيات ولكن اعتقد انه
يشبهه بالسفينه
اعتقد يشبه بالسفينه فهذا التشبيه هو طبعا
الشعر يعني عظمه الشعر انه هو
مغني للغه
اتكلم عن الشعر العربي مغني للغه العربيه
من ناحيه الالفاظ اغنائها لفظيا واغنائها
دلاليا
بمعنى انه الشاعر هو الوحيد الذي يستطيع
ان يخترع اسماء
ويضعها في القصيده وتصبح مقبوله في
المجتمع
من العصر الجاهلي ترى بالمناسبه يمكن
اليوم المجامع اللغه العربيه تضع اسماء
وكذا بس الشاعر عنده هذه العبقريه يعني
مثلا لما يقول
امرؤ القيس
مكرم مفر مقبل مدبر معا كجلمود صخر حطه
السيل من علي له اي طلابيا وساقانا عامه
وارضاء سرحان وتقريب تتفل المهم انه في
الاخير بيصفوا قيد الاوابدي هيكلي انه هو
يصف قيد الاوامر الاوابد هي الوحوش يعني
الحيوانات البريه قيد الاوابد هو الحيوان
الذي يقيد الاوابد كيف يقيدها بسرعه يصل
لها فتخيل هذا اللفظ التركيب اصبح اسم من
اسماء الخير
لانه امرؤ القيس قالوا وانه خيل قيد الاوى
اصبح من اسماء الخير تقراها قيد الاوابت
اذا احد قال لك قيد الاوابت تعرف انه اسم
الخير
هذا الغنى مثلا من اسماء النعام من
الاشياء الطريفه طبعا الاسماء ليش كثيره
يعني ممكن
تنسب للصوت الكائن ممكن تنسب لشكل الكائن
ممكن تنسب لسلوك الكائن يعني مثلا من
اسماء النعام اسم طريف كذا اسمه نقنق نقنق
اي نقنق من وين جايه من الصوت حق استكاك
المنقار
فيسمون نقنق فمثلا
وهذا ترى تجده في الشعر يعني كثير
مثلا من اسماء الجفول
الجفول يعني الذي يجفل يعني سريع الخوف
يعني ليش جفون لانه هو فعلا خواف يعني
سريع الخوف
طبعا الخوف
النعام الصعل
الصعل يعني اللي
راسه صغيره
الاصك الا ما له اذان في خرم بس ما في اذن
اوكي اسك
اعرف الاسماء جايه من شكل الكائن ومن
تكريس هذه الصفات المظهريه والصفات
السلوكيه في الشعر طبعا الشعر مقبول يعني
حتى كثيرين يقول يعني يجوز للشاعر ما لا
يجوز لغيره يعني انه هو يعني يوظف طبعا هو
اما انه يخترع لفظه جديده او
يضيف دلاله جديده الدلاله بمعنى انه
اللفظه نفسها ممكن تجد في القاموس لها
عشرين معنى حسب السياق التي تجي فيه
الكلمه لكن من يضيف المعاني الجديده
الشاعر في توظيفه هذه اللفظ
بيضيف معاني جديده والان بالمناسبه في
قاموس للغه العربيه
مشتغله عليه الشارقه هيئه الثقافه والتراث
الشارقه
تتبع
التطور الدلالي لالفاظ اللغه العربيه
هذا شيء عظيم مش زي القاموس العادي مثلا
افتح القى كلمه الكلمه هذه في العصر
الجاهلي كان معناها كذا وكذا وكذا هو
يعطيك ما في في القواميس كذا تفتح القاموس
اي قاموس اللغه العربيه يقول لك الكلمه ذي
لها عشرين معنى او 30 معنى هذه معانيه كذا
بس ما يقول لك حسب المرحله التاريخيه لا
هذا المعجم الجديد يقول لك في العصر
الجاهلي كانت تعني كذا وكذا اعتقد ان
قطر يعمل على نفس يعني طبعا هو ترى
بالمناسبه للان صدر منه مش عارف 70 او 80
مجلد وما انتهوا كم حرف
الكتروني وفيها
هذه المساله الدلاليه للكلمات هو طبعا
الدلاليه ربط البعد الدلالي بالفتره
الزمنيه ليش مهم هذا لاني لما اقرا نص
من العصر الجاهلي مثلا قصيده جاهليه
اللفظه ليست بمعنى هذا اليوم
الدلاله يعني كانت تعني شيء اخر
في نقطه على الحيوانات المستانسه واللي
كانت بريه
ان الاشياء البريه هي
وحشيه صحيح صحيح فمعناه ان الخروف كان
محشي
ايش يعني وحشي وحشي الكائن البري
طبعا هم يسموها في اللغه الاوابت اول وحوش
يعني كائنات وحشي بمعنى
يستوحش الناس
يعني انا ما يستانسوا المستانس هذا يانس
بوجود الناس ويقرب من الناس ومن التجمعات
البشريه الوحش لا من يشوف الناس
يهجير مثلا ولا الجاموس انها شيء خطير على
الانسان اليوم موجود في انواع من الظبا من
الخرفان اللي هي الضان بريه بريه ولو
تشوفوا في طبيعته طبعا ممكن بري وتجيبه
وتستانس
فحيصبح مستانس لكنه مستانس اقصد بينه هو
بري لكنه سلوكه تحول الى سلوك مستانس لكنه
في وضعه الطبيعي سيجفر من الانسان هذا هو
المعنى انه وحشي مش وحشي انه متوحش او
عشان كذا التسلسل الدلالي حسب الزمن مهم
فماذا تعني كلمه وحشي
في كل يوم